apparemment ça fait combien de temps
vous l'avez pas vu 28 ans vous avez quel
âge
28 il avait essayé de la chercher ou pas
oui ça fait quatre ans maintenant 80
blessés d'achraf et aurélie je sais que
c'était votre souhait aussi qu'il
retrouve sa maman ce soir oui ce sera
mieux parce que oui malheureusement on a
reçu des lettres et tout de sa mère - ya
quatre ans et on g j'ai fait d'énormes
recherche mais malheureusement soi même
mais les portes sont fermées mais vous
êtes venus vers nous oui vous avez
associe avec patricia tags etc on est en
contact depuis travaillé avec nous deux
milieux 14 maintenant travailler avec
nous et vous l'avez demandé
on aimerait retrouver la maman de
dimitri moment de dimitri et elle a dû
se séparer de vous très tôt parce
qu'elle n'avait pas les moyens de 2,2 de
subvenir aux besoins d'une famille c'est
ça un dimitri oui c'est un peu ça enfin
non je pense surtout aussi que d'après
ses lettres alors été forcé d'abandonner
donc comme ça c'est ça et bien dimitri
on a retrouvé votre maman puisque marie
christine et là ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les
chérie je pense qu'on va faire quelque
chose
c'est on va vous avez avoir besoin de
vous retrouver 28 ans sans vous voir
marie-christine tchèque marek et si vous
avez toujours gardé une photo de dimitri
qu'il avait toujours sur vous m'avez
montré voilà et je crois que c'est un
très beau jour pour vous ce soir
merci il traite raclage de répondu alors
dont la syrie moi j'ai envie de vous
dire j'ai envie que vous vous retrouviez
on va pas papa voilà tranquille ensemble
pendant un week-end tous les quatre on
va vous offrir un petit week-end pour
que vous vous retrouviez vous soyez bien
je suis très très très heureux pour vous
donnez nous des nouvelles
incroyable mais que vous savez qu'en
plus je vous le dis vous habitez à
quelques kilomètres un autre